good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Joe Biden announced he
was running for president again in April
of 2019. it was Biden's third or fourth
attempt at the office depending how you
count so at that moment most Americans
thought they knew who Joe Biden was
after 50 years in office they were
familiar with his face but it turns out
they weren't familiar with his new face
two months later Biden appeared on stage
in Miami for the first Democratic
primary debate and he was hard to
recognize even for people who had known
him extensive plastic surgery made him
look like a different person but most
jarring was the fact that he did not
sound like the old Joe Biden you
probably remembered Biden as blustery
and jovial Irish charm by the bucket
load he was famous for that and yet on
stage Biden came off as remote and muted
he seemed to be at times afraid to speak
for fear of tripping over words or
forgetting them
several times the camera caught him just
staring out into The Middle's distance
he was apparently absorbed in memory
when Biden did manage to focus his
attention he seemed highly annoyed
whatever the cause Democratic primary
voters were not impressed by his
performance Joe Biden's numbers dropped
10 points overnight
now the Biden campaign has never
explained what exactly happened to Joe
Biden that night in Miami but whatever
it was it never got fixed it continues
from that day until now probably the
most authentic feature of Joe Biden's
public performances has been his anger
that seems to come over him in waves
watch focus on this man what he's doing
that no president has ever done no
president no I haven't taken the test
why the hell would I take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program you take
a test where you're taking cocaine or
not what do you think huh
are you a joke I'm not out of time you
spoke over time and I'm going to talk
here's the deal
back to the matter is
look at what's happening here well
that's not true you're saying things you
do not know what you're talking about no
one said that who said that he said that
you said I set up my son to work on an
oil company isn't that what you said I
got your word straight Jack
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
so you know exactly what that is you've
seen it in people around you people you
love
there's nothing to do with politics what
you just saw is a man who is losing the
ability to regulate his emotions
uncontrollable flashes of anger are
common among people who are aging
particularly among men and they often
accompany senility losing it is a very
frustrating experience and your heart
goes out to anyone who is we have deep
sympathy for anyone in that position
including Joe Biden but Biden is the
president of the United States and this
is the single most volatile moment in
the recent history of our country Biden
is leading the U.S toward War
and so it's fair to assess the effect on
the rest of us of his mental and
emotional conditions not simply about
age Biden is 79. Biden is clearly unable
to speak with precision and when you're
president United States and the world
hangs on your every word when your words
constitute American policy when you can
change American policy particularly
America's foreign policy simply by
saying so
it is essential that you speak the words
you intend to speak that you not get
carried away because you're mad and say
something you don't mean that might
threaten the long-term interests of this
country threaten the families and the
children of the rest of us and our
future
but he is that's exactly what he's doing
that's not a partisan attack it's true
if you doubt that it's true watch his
performance just over the past week on
Thursday for example Joe Biden was asked
how the United States would respond if
the Russian government used chemical
weapons in Ukraine now that's a
hypothetical question presidents at the
podium often get those presidents rarely
respond to hypothetical questions for a
very simple reason they don't know the
circumstances ahead of time so there's
no reason to risk American Prestige or
to terrify the rest of the World by
saying the wrong thing so they don't
Biden had no obligation to answer that
question very few presidents would have
answered it but Biden did answer it and
here's what he said
And to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in Ukraine
would that trigger a military spot
response from NATO it would be it would
trigger a response and kind whether or
not you're asking whether NATO would
cross we'd make that decision at the
time
so he's closing his eyes trying to
remember what the cue card says what's
our policy and what he comes out with is
if Russia uses chemical weapons the U.S
will respond in kind if Russia uses new
chemical weapons the United States will
use chemical weapons
so no American president has said
anything like that in your lifetime you
grew up assuming the United States would
never use chemical weapons because the
United States is not a rogue state in
fact our role globally is to suppress
Rogue States they tell us that's what
we're doing right now
and yet in a flash of peak because he
couldn't remember the correct words Joe
Biden the president of the United States
reversed a hundred years of American
security policy in the middle of a war
this did not escape the attention of his
own National Security advisor who
instantly responded by restoring the
status quo or attempting to quote the
United States has no intention of using
chemical weapons period under any
circumstances said Jake Sullivan flatly
contradicting his boss no one who works
for the president wants to do that but
Jake Sullivan had no choice he works for
a man who cannot even pronounce his own
vice president's name consistently and
yet is in charge of the United States at
the most delicate moment in our
lifetimes
but Biden didn't slow down he kept going
the next day his advisors allowed him to
fly to Poland to quote rally the
International Community in support of
Ukraine and while in Poland Biden met
with soldiers from the 82nd Airborne
they're currently stationed there as
cameras rolled Joe Biden informed these
soldiers that they would soon be sent to
Ukraine watch this
the average citizen looking how they're
stepping up
could either stepping up
and you're going to see when you're
there and sometimes you've been there
you're going to see you're going to see
women young people stand on a stand in
the middle of the front of a damn tank
it's just saying I'm not leaving I'm
holding my ground
so the previous president was often
criticized sometime with justification
for not using words precisely you're the
president you can't just tweet out
anything that's the case you heard for
four years and again it was often rooted
in truth but the last president never
said anything that even approaches the
crazed recklessness of what you just
heard you're gonna see when you're there
where in Ukraine
so the 82nd Airborne apparently is going
to Ukraine their commander-in-chief just
told them that of course they had no
idea neither did their families neither
did anyone in the United States until
Joe Biden said it live on Friday the
White House didn't even know
Fox News reached out to Biden's
spokesman after those remarks and no one
there no one in the white house seemed
aware that those remarks have been
caught on tape
so how to explain this abrupt change in
American foreign policy
quote the president has been clear we
are not sending U.S troops to Ukraine
and there is no change in that position
end quote so for the second time in
three days
the Administration has to flatly
contradict the commander-in-chief and
not on a minor question these are often
written off as a gaffe no a gaff
is when you mispronounce somebody's name
telling troops they're going to be sent
to Ukraine pledging the United States is
going to use chemical weapons these are
not gaffes
these are something else they're
dangerous that's for sure so the best
the White House can do is telling us
well the president by saying he's
sending American troops to Ukraine is
reaffirming our policy of not sending
U.S troops to Ukraine thanks for the
clarification what else could they say
and it got even weirder from there
on Saturday once again completely out of
nowhere with no warning whatsoever and
apparently no forethought Joe Biden
called for regime change in Russia watch
this
a dictator
man I'm rebuilding an Empire will never
erase the people's love for Liberty
brutality will never grind down their
will to be free
for God's sake this man cannot remain
power
doing his Churchill routine fine
things aren't going well at home all
presidents seek Solace abroad where
they're taken much more seriously than
they are by their own voters
but he couldn't stop himself for God's
sake this man cannot remain empowered
Joe Biden said of Vladimir Putin Now set
aside how you feel about Putin you
probably don't like him and for good
reason our policy according to the
president United States is to take Putin
out to remove him as head of state
to be clear regime change in Russia has
never been American policy and this is
hardly the first time we have Tangled
with Russia we've had far more
threatening circumstances than this one
the United States you'll recall waged a
proxy war against the Russian government
for 11 years in Vietnam nearly 60 000
Americans died in that war and yet no
American president mentioned regime
change at the Kremlin why because they
were soft on the Russians no
because Russia has about 6 000 nuclear
weapons
so let's say we eliminated the Russian
head of state and of course that
country's central government what would
happen to those weapons
well let's see in Iraq saddam's weapons
stockpiles all conventional wound up in
the hands of militia that used them to
kill Americans
so Russia has a large and restive
population of Islamic extremists
do we think it's possible that with no
one running the country because of
course we have no chosen successor to
Putin is it possible if we did that that
one of those 6 000 nuclear weapons might
wind up in the hands of some
anti-American terror group and be used
against our civilian population here a
nuclear weapon
less not just possible it's likely
and that's if we were to succeed in
killing Putin what if we don't kill
Putin as apparently is now our policy
the president United States just
informed the Russian government that he
seeks its overthrow so you have to ask
yourself does hearing that make Vladimir
Putin more or less likely to use a
nuclear weapon against the United States
and Western Europe how to trapped
animals behave well they lash out with
fangs and Claws desperate people are
dangerous people of course
so it would be in the interest of the
United States and that's the only
interest that matters from our
perspective to cool the rhetoric a
little bit or when you employ overheated
rhetoric to do it for a reason in the
service of a clearly articulated goal
that helps the United States and not
just because you're old and pissed which
is exactly what you just saw a guy who
just lost control of what he was saying
because he was too mad
it's all pretty obvious no one in
Washington has spent 30 seconds thinking
about what would happen if we knocked
off Putin or if we talk about knocking
off Putin in fact our foreign policy
establishment spent the weekend
congratulating Joe Biden on saying the
wrong thing they compared him to Ronald
Reagan
Washington loves regime change it's what
comes after regime change they'd rather
not consider and have no track record of
pulling off
but for now they were thrilled Bill
Crystal compared Biden's threat to
Reagan Telly Mikhail Gorbachev to tear
down this wall because everything in DC
is cliche based Rick Wilson agreed quote
Biden did tear down this wall for our
era again the cliches dumb people speak
and think in cliches because they have
no other terms at hand former White
House correspondent CBS News Mark
knoller said Biden was even better than
Ronald Reagan quote tops Reagan's 1987
tear down this wall speech okay
to its credit four Once the White House
did not run toward the Applause they're
apparently still an adult or two working
there and they immediately try to tell
us that Biden hadn't actually meant what
he told us on camera he didn't really
mean it any statement that begins this
way is a Lie the president's Point okay
we can discern his point he said it but
the president's point was that Putin
cannot be allowed to exercise power over
his neighbors or the region he was not
discussing Putin's power in Russia or
regime change
right well that's of course not true but
at least it's reassuring to know our
policy Remains the Same neocons in DC of
course were highly distressed CIA
operative Rodney farron for example
wrote this quote this would have been
Biden's tear down this wall moment but
for White House staffers watering down
his meaning afterward
a few hours ago Biden once again stepped
in front of the microphone and
reaffirmed that the words that had
accidentally slipped out of his mouth
over the weekend because he was mad at
me has no self-control are actually
officially U.S policy here's Joe Biden
do you believe what you said that Putin
can't remain in power or do you now
regret saying that because your
government has been trying to walk that
back did your words complicate matters
well yes three different questions I'll
answer them all number one I'm not
walking anything back
I'm not walking anything back so regime
change in Russia is now our policy
that's what the president of the United
States just told us and as he did he
rebuked the people who worked for him
which is fine with us they've spent all
week correcting statements that he makes
up on the Fly and hasn't thought through
in any way purely reactive Hey Joe Biden
what would be the long-term effect of
the United States of what you're doing
no idea
don't have to think about the future now
when everything is suddenly at stake
there's never been recklessness at this
level in the White House and yes that
includes the last president who was
often attacked for being Reckless
nothing he said compares to this
Fox's Peter Ducey asked for
clarification in response Joe Biden
revealed that he is completely unaware
that his staff has been continuously
updating American policy all week as he
changes it on the Fly watch Joe Biden
are you worried that other leaders in
the world are going to start to doubt
that America is back if some of these
big things that you say on the world
stage keep getting walked back let's get
him walk back it made it sound like just
in the last couple days uh it sounded
like you told US troops they were going
to Ukraine it sounded like you said it
was possible the U.S would use a
chemical weapon and it sounded like you
were calling for regime change in Russia
and we know none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three Mr
President you interpret the language
that way
what's getting walked back to be clear
he's not fit to lead particularly right
now
Bernie Sanders scared the hell out of
the banks Democratic party
short-circuited his campaign and
installed Joe Biden Biden seemed kind of
passive for a lot of Voters that was a
welcome respite from the last president
who seemed kind of loud okay that's
what's actually that's what actually
happened no one anticipated at that
moment that we would be on the cusp of a
war with the nuclear armed power in less
than two years but that's exactly where
we are now and under those circumstances
to have someone who has literally no
idea what's going on doesn't even know
that he's changing long-standing
policies that adults have thought
through when he does it
just scary describe that no it's worse
so Biden just said everything that he
has said for the last week
is true and none of it has been
corrected by people who work for him
the truth is Joe Biden has no idea
Joe Biden has no idea what his
publicists say when he goes to sleep
that Midway through his answer Biden
starts walking back his own Commons he
does that just minutes after saying he
would never walk back his own comments
none of that occurred Biden said look it
feels almost like we're being mean to
the guy by quoting him and no one wants
that no one is making fun of his age or
his diminished condition only trying to
defend the country then moments later
Biden declared that no reasonable person
would think he wants regime change in
Russia watch this if you can stand it
because it's ridiculous
nobody believes we're going to take down
I was going to I was talking about
taking down Putin
nobody would believe that
all right joke's over too much is at
stake as there was ever a time if there
was in U.S history ever a time to invoke
the 25th Amendment it is now as Joe
Biden himself put it for God's sakes
this man cannot remain in power
for all of our sakes subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight